[Music]
yes Jeremy a lot of us were really
saddened at the passing of Stephen
Hawking
he was definitely an inspiration he was
one of the most brilliant theoretical
physicists in the world and of course he
overcame this incredible disability his
life was very difficult and very
dramatic and I for one am really gonna
miss having him around and I certainly
miss him as a scientist too he made some
incredible contributions now Stephen
Hawking was something that we call a
theoretical physicist and what that
means is that people use the mathematics
of physics to explore areas of the
universe that we can't get to very
easily you know for example conditions
right after the Big Bang the beginning
of the universe what were things like
when the universe was a fraction of a
second old that's not something we can
create very easily in a laboratory or
not not any place we can go to but we
can use our mathematics to predict what
that would have been like and then test
our assumptions based on how the
universe changed over time and one of
the places that is also very difficult
to go to is could we explore a black
hole and this is what Stephen Hawking
was best known for now black holes are
massive objects they're made from
collapsed dead stars and the nearest
black hole to us is about 3,000 light
years away that one's not particularly
large that's only a couple times the
mass of the Sun the the biggest black
hole that's in our galaxy is about four
million times the mass of the Sun and
that actually sits right in the heart of
the Milky Way galaxy and right now you
and I are actually orbiting that giant
black hole at half a million miles an
hour these are incredibly exotic objects
the reason we call them black holes is
that the gravity is so intense it can
suck in everything including light not
even light you know going going through
space freely at the speed of light can
escape a black hole so I mean talk about
dramatic exotic objects that are
difficult to do experiments on Stephen
Hawking laid down some of our basic
understanding of how a black hole works
and one of the things he actually did
was even predict that black holes can
die you would think that a collapsed
star that forms a bottomless pit of
gravity would exist forever
but Stephen Hawking used the laws of
quantum mechanics and something called
thermodynamics how heat behaves in the
universe to prove that maybe black holes
can evaporate over time and of course
that's a hugely significant thing one of
the reasons I think it's very
unfortunate he died is we're actually
right on the cusp of being able to do
actual experiments with black holes and
I know that sounds like a strange thing
to say but there are some particle
accelerators I mean specifically the
Large Hadron Collider which is in Europe
that are about to get too high enough
energies they're going to smash
particles together so hard that so much
energy is generated they might be able
to make tiny little black holes and by
the way this is entirely safe don't
worry about it at all
Stephen Hawking showed us that black
holes evaporate they actually die away
and the smaller a black hole is the
faster this happens so these little
black holes will probably be lucky if we
can detect them they're going to die in
millionths of a second and the Large
Hadron Collider gets nowhere upto the
energy of natural events all around us
right now they're high-energy particles
slamming into our atmosphere a couple
miles above our heads and there are many
many hundreds of times the energy that
the Large Hadron Collider will ever be
able to get up to so I am saying
actually that that there are probably
tiny little black holes forming all
around us they evaporate away so quickly
they're very hard to detect Stephen
Hawking predicted the exact energy that
black holes give off when they evaporate
and it may be that in just a few years
time we're going to observe that in a
particle accelerator and realize he was
right now there's another thing that's
kind of poignant and that Stephen
Hawking just before his death just in
the last couple of years was beginning
to unravel some of his previous theories
he thought that maybe we had all been
fooled and maybe black holes don't work
the way we thought they did now we know
black holes exist we see these massive
objects in the middle of galaxies or you
know up in the sky with the Stars we
know that they're there but he thought
that maybe we really don't understand
how an event horizon works an event
horizon is the but basically the point
of no return you can't get any closer to
a black hole and escape
even light cannot escape this event
horizon and Stephen Hawking began to
wonder if quantum mechanics doesn't
really allow a true event horizon you
may have heard of something called
quantum entanglement that you can take
two particles and you can actually
combine them in such a way that they
respond to each other they have to
actually adjust to what the other
particle is doing we don't understand
this very well yet we've known about it
for a hundred years even Albert Einstein
knew about quantum entanglement but what
happens if you take two particles that
are linked in this way and one goes down
a black hole and you still have the
other one is it possible that these two
particles can still talk to each other
even though one is beyond the event
horizon and no information should be
able to get out this question was
starting to lead Stephen Hawking in a
new direction he was starting to think
that maybe quantum entanglement was a
proof that our simple understanding of
black holes was wrong and he was
starting to formulate new ideas about
how black holes could work with quantum
entanglement and he's not here right now
to lead us on that anymore and yes there
are a brilliant physicist that will take
over and I think we'll discover things
about quantum entanglement and how black
holes might deal with that I think it
may lead to a breakthrough which is the
equivalent of another Einstein I think
it may be that our current laws of
physics are going to fall apart because
right now we cannot understand how
quantum entanglement and a black hole
could possibly work together when we do
we're gonna have a brand new physics and
in a way Stephen Hawking will be one of
the parents of that
[Music]